hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
on a modern approach to traditional
virology research
i am lisa burkeby from nexon bioscience
where we have a team of experts in the
science of cell counting and cell-based
essays
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i am excited to introduce our first
speaker dr rushika pereira
from the center for vectorborne and
infectious disease at colorado state
university
for a complete biography on dr pereira
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr pereira you may now begin your
presentation
thank you to naxalong for having me uh
here and
allowing me to share my um work
so my laboratory has been heavily
involved in antiviral testing against
stars for v2 so i thought i'd share some
of our experiences
but also really share some of the
thoughts we have going forward
in terms of breaking the
glass ceiling where antiviral
therapeutics and
interventions for infectious disease are
concerned i'm
my laboratory is primarily interested in
understanding
the infinite interactions between
pathogen and host
and how those infinite interactions can
be studied using systems biology
and in the antiviral therapeutic space
i'm interested in using systems biology
to understand how
antivirus can alter or be altered by
the metabolic interactions between
pathogen and host
so as uh kovid19 hit we had a
plethora of people needing to test the
antivirus
colorado state university has a large
bsl3 space
and therefore we set up the space to uh
and a special
respiratory virus ring to um
be able to cater to the world
inventories
uh to test their their products so we've
been involved in testing antivirals
disinfectants in helens and biologics
so we share some of that information now
so we really took on three phases to our
approach
the first phase was to establish um
conditions so that we can establish
basic assays for antiviral testing
to diversify platforms and be able to
really produce
rigorous data the second phase was to
really develop synergy models for
combination therapeutics which is where
uh the therapeutic space is really
strong
with specifics like heparitis c and hiv
being productive in that space and the
the third phase was to really understand
virus host interactions
and how the metabolic space of a host
might alter the efficacy of
uh therapeutics and interventions so i
will go through the first phase and
describe some of the essays we have
developed
so for sars we are using the washington
uh strain
of sars cov2 several cell lines have
been
used in our assays vero human hepatoma
cali3 keco and some primary cells
rss in vitro have included
cytoprotection
cytotoxicity plaque assays high content
imaging using the selego from epsilon
and qrt pcr we also have the capacity to
because we are a wet school we have the
capacity to use animal models so my
colleagues dick bowen and tony shounds
have been helping with
hamster dmrs and bat animal models to
test some of these antivirals
so some of the assays that we started
producing for antiviral testing
required that we demonstrate
reproducibility so in this slide on the
left what you can see is two operators
and two independent experiments testing
a
fda approved drug and you can see that
we were able to really produce
uh rigorous uh data with a little
code efficient or variation we also were
able to demonstrate as
shown in the center
fda approved drugs that and be able to
show that we can get the same
ec 50 as published we also diversified
our platforms for instance we're looking
at
virus output using black assays virus
spread from cell to cell using
immunofluorescence and then we can also
look at particle
infectivity and genome replication using
qrt pcr
one of the important things that we
established at the beginning was
that a lot of the cell cytotoxicity
assays that were being used in the field
were not really appropriate for a lot of
these antivirals and
other compounds that we were testing
primarily because those compounds
were affecting cell metabolism
and so we really wanted to focus just on
the impact of the compound
on the virus rather than the impact of
the compound on the cell
or the solvent on the cell and so we had
to establish
as you can see going to the to the right
um in orange is a higher cell density
and in green is a lower cell density
and we discovered that aopi staining
using the cell ego from epsilon as well
as neutral red assays
were the best at determining
cell cytotoxicity uh making sure that
the compound was not affected by the
assay
so i'll show you some data from
disinfectants and inhalants
so there are there is a large repertoire
of disinfectants that we're testing for
many different countries and what we do
with disinfectants as shown on the left
is that we mix the disinfectant at
different ratios with the virus
and incubate it for several minutes or
hours
and then we look to see how much virus
is left by
doing a plaque reduction assay and as
you can see this
specific disinfectant um reduced
virus infectivity significantly by
several logs
this disinfectant has now gone on to fda
approval on the right is uh inhalants
this is an
inhalant that is normally used for tb
patients
and so we tested it against sars and we
were able to show that it actually
was antiviral this inhelent has
gone on to phase two clinical trials
we've also worked with nexalom to look
at visualization based hydropoot assays
for antiviral
triaging in this case i will
show you an example of a biologic as you
all might know the seligo is
a really powerful instrument
to help us evaluate a whole 96 well
plate using visualization
as to whether a compound can be
antiviral or not
we can um quantify cells
on a quadrant basis and um establish
whether the cells are alive
or dead using staining and we can also
uh stain for the virus
so this is uh results from the saligo
and in this case
on the left graph on the y-axis is cell
count and on the
x-axis is different concentrations of
the natural product
in blue is dead cells in green
are live cells using ao staining and
then
in brown is virus titer and what you can
see as you move to the right on that
x axis you can see that the red arrow is
pointing to a concentration
that is showing lower dead cells
increased live cells and low virus so
this means that if the
cells are alive the virus is not
replicating
and so using selego imaging we were able
to
demonstrate that aopi staining can
just tell us whether the drug is working
or not
and on the right hand side is a
validation of that assay
using basic black acids showing the
exact same
concentration is antiviral
and on the bottom is an image of our
wells
and as you go to the right you can see
that you can
look at more dead cells taking
we're also able to use the seligo to
look at cell to cell spread
this was really important when uh you're
dealing with
cells that do not output virus as
efficiently as various cells for
instance
so human cells um don't output viruses
uh well and so we need to look at the
cells and how well the virus is
replicating in those cells using
antibodies
against the virus so this is an image of
vero cells
stained with the antibody against the
end protein
and you can see on the first panel is
infected cells
and on the other panels are controls and
so it's very clearly demonstrating that
we can
look at cell to cell spread using the
selego
so we're continuing to test fda approved
drugs investigational compounds
srnas biologics and antibodies
i will now uh describe a little bit of
the work that we've done
in developing synergy models for
combination therapeutics
this manuscript will be submitted for
publication in the next few weeks
so one of the biggest antiviral uh one
of the biggest
bottlenecks to end the in the antiviral
space is that we use monotherapies
and when you use single drugs or
monotherapies
you have to use a higher dose and as a
result you have multiple complications
where patients might have idiosyncratic
hyper reactive
hyperreactive or tachyphylaxis in
reactions and also it impacts
comorbidities
and so the the as i said before for
hepatitis c and hiv
we have been able to really demonstrate
um
that combination therapeutics are
powerful and so
the goal of this study was to really
identify
fda-approved drugs that could be used in
combination
to combat kobit-19
and so what you see here is some of our
results on the left
most side it describes our
scheme so we have drug a which is
directly targeting the virus
drug b is a host targeted drug and run c
is a host targeted drug as well and if
you combine
all three you have multiple effects that
you can expect
one is that it could be antagonistic so
drug a
could be antagonized by the presence of
b and c
and any in any combination
we could also have additive effects
which is okay
but not ideal where you have drug a and
b
and c impacted in an additive fashion
what we're really looking for is a
synergistic antiviral
surface and what that means is that the
drug
a effective concentration
will be improved or dropped
in the presence of drug b and c so drug
a's efficacy is increased by the
presence of drug b
and c and vice versa so what we were
able to show
in the third panel that you see is that
in blue
is the virus control in orange is one
drug
drug a in uh yellow is drug a
plus b and in green is drug a plus b
plus c and what you see here is that we
can have a two and a half delay with the
triple drug
uh combination um as measured by
cytopathic effect
and on the rightmost panel you can see
that this
these results are also displayed in
terms of
infectious virus production and we get a
six log
drop in virus production in in the
presence of three drugs
versus two or a single drug so this was
really
um effective and it shows that you don't
have to use
a lot of drug if you do it in
combination
so as the last um set of
slides i will describe where we are
going um
in terms of our antiviral work and also
in the therapeutic space
so i'm a systems biologist and really
interested in metabolism
and how host metabolism is altered by
its uh
exposure types so a human or a mosquito
or any
uh organism that you're studying uh
whether it's a plant or an animal
can be impacted by what it is exposed to
whether it's a bitten by a mosquito
vector whether it's infected by bacteria
or viral pathogens
um the microbiome vaccinations
and therapeutics as well as the
environment
and as you uh are impacted by these
exposures
in the in historically we've been
studying
how the genetics of the organism changes
how the transcriptome of the organism
changes using transcriptomics
and how the proteome of the organism
changes we've really
paid little attention to what is
downstream of all of these
genes and transcripts and proteins and
that's metabolites
metabolites are the final products or
the intermediates of
all biochemical pathways that are active
at any given moment
in a human and they are also
the effectors of a phenotype so they are
directly related to your phenotype
so it's better to look at the active
metabolic
landscape of a human at any given point
in time
and then be able to dial back and figure
out which protein
which transcript and which gene might be
active
so basically metabolites are
intermediates and products of active
biochemical pathways so they are the
most direct relationship to a phenotype
if you measure them you can identify
uh you can obtain much information
including
uh the the fact that they're small
molecule biomarkers of infection
tissue damage your immune response
a pathogen-specific response and
treatment efficacy
so the measurement of these metabolites
is a powerful conduit to
get gaining much information about your
disease day
most importantly species independent so
glucose is glucose whether it's in the
human
or the mouse or the monkey or the
mosquito
and the most critical realization
is that metabolites are what your drugs
and inhibitors
are and so basically by looking at what
natural metabolites might be altered in
your human body
during infection you're really
identifying drugs that could be used to
alter that metabolic landscape
so what we're really interested in is
using systems biology
based therapeutics to look at drug
interactions
so whether drugs can be synergistic or
dysergistic
drug metabolism does a drug get broken
down in your human body and if it does
do those metabolites alter the
therapeutic
efficacy or the infectious condition
of the human what do co-infections do
bacterial metabolites might impact
therapeutic efficacy or
infection state
the microbiome have its impact on drug
mode of action synergy and infection
and ideally long term what we're going
towards is
not every drug or combination is ideal
for everybody
as you know kobe 19 is plagued by the
fact that there are many comorbidities
that are exacerbating their conditions
and the outcome and so we really think
that individualistic
medicine by looking at us a
human's metabolic state and identifying
what drug combinations might be useful
um is the way to go
so with that i'd like to uh acknowledge
and
uh our contributors so elena liang was a
and gabriel ramirez were undergraduates
in my um laboratory that had the amazing
experience of being able to work on sars
in a bsl-3 laboratory
they have both entered the phd program
now
kali mcallister also was uh instrumental
in a lot of this work and is continuing
this work she's a master's student who
is now a research associate in my lab
and who i don't have here is laura
sinclair who
is a graduate student and also helping
with several essays
brian and david are my co-and my
colleagues in the
in the antiviral effort david is
the vice president for translation and
helps with a lot of the mtas and cdas
that
and the paperwork and also on an
advisory role
and brian also helps on an advisory work
i'd like to acknowledge funding i'm a
co-director of the center for metabolism
of infectious disease where we're really
pursuing some of these futuristic ideas
the officer vice president for research
for their contribution to setting up the
antiviral
facility and also the bachelor
foundation
kovid bar medical research innovation
grant thank you
thanks dr pereira that was great i
would like to now introduce our second
speaker dr suzanne riches
who is a field application scientist
here at nexolon and one of our most
popular speakers
for a complete biography on dr rich's
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr riches you
may now begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction lisa and
thank you to dr pereira as well for a
really
really nice talk um i'll spend the next
15 minutes of the session just
discussing some data
from some other virology labs and show
how we at nexalon
are modernizing traditional virology
research
so um the first time i presented on this
topic um
was in may this year and at that point
we were in the middle of a lockdown at
least in the uk
due to covert 19 and at that point there
were 5.6 million
total confirmed cases globally and
around
90 000 new cases per day happening
so globally we were all pretty worried
but hopeful that the lockdown rules
would mean that those numbers should
start to come down
and the infection rates should slow down
as well
the situation now is that there have
been over 50 million global
cases in total and the daily case rate
is at 600
000 cases per day um there are of course
a lot of reasons for this data other
than simply the enhanced spread of the
virus
more regular and reliable testing across
the world is being one of those reasons
why the data
is a lot higher but really my main point
here is that we're still in the midst of
a pandemic
and the faster we can conduct vitally
important virology research will equal
the faster production
of validated vaccines and efficient
treatments and it's really great news
this week
about the pfizer and bioentech
collaboration
creating the vaccine
so there is a lot of fantastic research
going on all over the world at the
moment and it's difficult to summarize
that in just one slide but i wanted to
try
and summarize specifically the ongoing
laboratory research
and i've tried to summarize that into a
few main categories
the screening of antiviral drugs and the
screening of new vaccines are the two
major areas that are spoken about on a
regular basis
but there's also some other areas as
well researching the pathogenesis
of the virus itself regarding things
like replication cycle
and virus spread can be a really big
help
another arm of virology research will be
to monitor the immune response
in relation to vaccines and antivirals
so this area of study
sort of goes hand in hand with the
others
evaluation of pre-clinical models and of
course the processing of
all the diagnostic tests and the
creation of accurate diagnostic tests
are other major areas of laboratory
research
so following on from this my next
question is what experiments are these
labs routinely performing to get the
data that they need
so within the typical covert 19 in vitro
virology lab there are a few key
cell-based experimental techniques that
are used
and the technique that has really stood
the test of time is
the lytic plaque assay a variation of
that plaque assay is the focus formation
assay and these clusters of infected
fluorescent cells or foci can be
analyzed
in a similar way to the lytic plaque
assay
cytopathic effect that experiment is an
assessment of the host cell monolayer
and is normally
determined by quantifying the percentage
of host cells still alive
after infection
infectivity and neutralization assays
are probably the most common application
i've seen
in the virology labs and will simply
determine what percentage
of the total host population are
infected
and the neutralization aspect then comes
when you add an antibody
into the experiment in order to block
that infection
t cell activation is just one of many
examples of ways we can gain more
knowledge on how the immune cells are
responding to vaccines and antivirals
and finally all of the above experiments
can be done in conjunction with looking
at cytotoxicity proliferation
or morphology changes of the cells dr
pereira
showed some really nice fluorescent
images
of virus infectivity and some
cytotoxicity
and so i would like to focus on a couple
of the other applications in the list to
show you how we at nexlum are helping
to progress research in these areas
so before i show you some data i wanted
to mention some of the more classical
methods
of doing these experiments flow
cytometry is a method that will give you
really great sensitivity allow lots of
flexibility when it comes to using
multiple fluorophores
however the speed of this method is slow
there is extra maintenance required
large sample volumes etc
meaning that um if you are doing
screening
using this method it's going to take a
very long time
and that time to get results for our
current covered situation is something
that we need to reduce as much as we can
manual microscopy is still a gold
standard in a lot of
assays and experiments but the very slow
speed
coupled with no way really of easily
analyzing your images
after taking them again means that doing
any type of screening
using this method is pretty impossible
so we're really excited that so many
virology labs are now adopting
image cytometry technology for these
kind of assays and the ones i previously
mentioned
so the seligo by next along is the image
image cytometer you can see in the
middle
of the slide there and to summarize it
as briefly as i can it's a multi-channel
fluorescent and bright field microscope
plus automatic stage movement allowing
images to be automatically focused
and captured from well to well and in
multiple channels as well
plus the seligo is coupled with
automatic analysis software to produce
quantitative data based on those images
the points i really love about the
selego are that
um they're made to enable you to image
your cells within your plates with no
disruption
so those cells can be live or they can
be fixed
uh they need very little maintenance i'm
talking about the seliga machines now
there's no fluidics no contamination and
they're really easy to operate
and they're really fast so compared to a
flow cytometer or manual microscope
high throughput experiments will be
completed in a in a fraction
of the time um and in addition to this
you'll also get beautiful
really nice publication worthy images to
back your data up
so now i'd like to go through some data
and images you can expect to see
on the selego
so i wanted to start with the most
classical of all the virology
applications a lytic plaque assay for
this example vero cell monolayers were
infected with a virus
and then incubated for 36 hours the
monolayers were then fixed
and stained with crystal violet
quantifying the number of lytic plaques
per well was previously done manually
by eye by this lab so they used to hold
their plate up to the light to try and
count how many plaques were in there
but our aim was to use the selego and it
was to look at an earlier time point
than they're currently doing
and to save them that overall
experimental time
so this is the normal point the group
would count lytic plaques by i which is
the 36 hour time point
this can be done by image cytometry
methods too and i can show you
a zoomed in image here the green
segmentation on the right
um they outline each lytic plaque
and i'm just showing you here how the
image cytometer analysis software
detects
each of those plaques even when plaques
are merging
and the settings can still be optimized
to count accurately
and these merging plaques would be
really difficult to see by eye
remembering this is in a
12 roll 12 well plate this is a single
well
and it's going to cause a lot of user to
use a variability
if you try and count the plaques in a
well looking like this
even at lower virus concentrations like
in this second well
uh there will still be merging plaques
which can be
interpreted differently uh by various
individuals when counting manually by
eye
and using the image cytometer the selego
means you can enlarge these images and
get a better understanding
of whether this is indeed two merging
plaques or just one single plaque and
ultimately it will give you really
accurate and consistent
analysis
so we can also consider that earlier
experimental time point where plaques
would not normally be able to be
quantified by eye
so this is exactly the same plate this
is just 24 hours earlier than the
previous
images what we can see here you can just
about see
the plaques in those images there um on
the right hand side
the green fill option is um
is activated that's a analysis option on
the selego just allowing you to see what
plaques have been
identified and we can just see that all
those even those small plaques can be
identified nice and accurately
on the selego
so to summarize this experiment image
cytometry enables you to detect
the plaques earlier which means a whole
day of experimental time
is now saved in addition
extra data showing the average size of
those plaques is also available
and automatically calculated which could
definitely not
be something that you do by eye
and finally and there's been so many
labs that i've gone into where i've seen
walls uh mountains of plaque
plates stacked up but with the selego
all of your images are digitally
archived so there's no need
for these walls of plates anymore
so if you wanted to see some published
data on justice then there's a
publication from biogen
it's a good place to start biogen or a
gene therapy company in boston
and who now automate their plaque assays
using image cytometry
in order to increase the speed
throughput sensitivity and robustness
of their assays
okay my uh my next experiment example is
one where cytopathic effect
is the readout now cytopathic effect it
can come in lots of
shapes and sizes but the most common
measurement performed is to quantify the
percentage of remaining host
cell monolayer after a number of days of
incubation with the virus of interest
so in this experiment we have some host
cells that were plated out and then
infected with emcv
and after incubation the remaining host
cell monolayers were stained with
crystal violet
and it's also important just for me to
mention here that the saline
with the silica you don't have to stain
the cells to assess the monolayer
you can do that without a stain and the
reason it was done
it was to compare by eye to a manual
scoring method to see if the results
were comparable
so here are some of the whole well
images from this experiment on the left
at low virus concentration we can see
the dark staining of the monolayer of
host cells
which is showing that the monolayer is
still alive and intact when the virus
concentration is low
but with increasing virus concentration
the host cell monolayer becomes depleted
so that's as you move from the left hand
side to the right hand side
results are automatically quantified as
a percentage
of host cells remaining in each well
which in this example
contains serial dilutions as you move
across the plate
we can see the results presented as a
heat map on the left hand side
that's all within the seligo software
and after exporting the data we can plot
that
to produce viral title curves and
determine tcid50s
the lab that this data is from are now
using this exact same method
um this exact same technique for their
covid19 research
and each plate and that you do with this
technique
takes just five minutes to scan and to
analyze
so as i mentioned before cpe comes in
many shapes and sizes and the
flexibility of the
analysis software of the celigo
will allow you to analyze these in
different ways
so this is an example from one of our
collaborators who are currently working
on
antivirals for covid19 so
firstly like in the example previously
we can simply assess the depletion of
the monolayer
so the green fill here isn't um
fluorescence
it's just the fill analysis option
on the selego and it just shows you
where cells are present
where cells are still present within
that well
an alternative option is to count the
total number of cells in each well so
cpe will be indicated here by an overall
reduction
in the number of cells these cells are
represented by the small green
dots within that image
and a final way of doing it is another
just a slightly different alternative
would be to determine the cpe
from looking at the morphology of the
cells so the rounding
up of cells could be an indication of
infection
and cells dying and this difference in
morphology from the healthy cells can be
quantified
and in this image here the more round
cells
in the monolayer are indicated by a red
cross
and if you'd like to see a fluorescent
alternative examining cpe then
researchers from the j craig ventner
institute are measuring cpe using a
green signal to show where healthy host
cells remain
after viral infection
just my last couple of slides now um
with
with those feature with these features
and the data i presented in mind i just
wanted to summarize
the advantages and the feedback we have
been getting from current selego users
who are doing covert 19 research and
those working on other viruses
too so the points in this slide i really
wanted to
focus on um are the getting results
earlier and the finishing projects
faster
one group i know uh were previously
doing their infectivity and
neutralization assays
on a flow cytometer for a small screen
this would take
around one week to complete the scan and
to get
all the data and now with the seligo
they can get the same data
same amount of data and it's all
comparable in just four hours
so if you extrapolate that further it
will mean that
candida antivirals and vaccines make
their way to animal models and then
ultimately into the clinic a lot faster
and considering there's currently six
hundred thousand new cases per day
globally i think this time saving
especially for covid research is
absolutely vital
and a great example of this type of
screening is happening in relation to
covert 19 by groups
at sanford burnham and at mount sinai
performing
and this paper just shows their drug
repurposing screen
that they did and without going into too
much detail they started with 12 000
compounds
and narrowed it down to 17 to take
further
and this was done using a combination of
image cytometry with other methods as
well
so before we go to questions i just also
wanted to mention our newest instrument
the
celica mx it's a high-throughput cell
counter
which will evaluate 24 cell samples
in less than three minutes and that's a
total of less than three minutes
um which is really relieving cell
counting bottlenecks in high throughput
labs so if you wanted to hear any more
about the celica there's not much time
in this talk
but please indicate that um at the end
um
and thank you very much for your time
and attention
thanks suzanne another great
presentation uh
it's time for q and a so if you have any
questions please enter them in the
question box
and i already have a couple to start and
it's great news to hear about progress
with covid19 vaccine
using mrna approach as an expert in the
field what are your thoughts
also should we be looking at
multi-pronged approaches
and do you think your metabolic approach
could improve the predictability
of an effect
treatment efficacious treatment
yes yes i can take that
um definitely we have to um
employ a multi-pronged approach and not
every vaccine is going to be
effective and long term and so i think
that
evaluating multiple candidates is really
important and having options
the metabolic landscape for sure is
important income
in terms of determining efficacy so
especially i think it becomes important
when people have diabetes or heart
disease
or metabolic syndrome which has shown to
exacerbate
kobe 19 morbidity so
and most of those uh conditions are due
to
metabolic disruption in your body mainly
glucose metabolism
and so it's really important to
determine how your immune response
is altered by the presence of elevated
metabolic disruptions
okay so this next one has a really long
comment with it
they say it is a really interesting
congratulations dr pereira and dr riches
i have always believed that medicine
should be individualized due to all the
different environments we have within
our own body
i'm a medic on a biomaterials materials
laboratory phd program
i'm really sad every day i hear a
professor dies due to the virus
i want to research about material for
improved face masks here
in the laboratory i've been reading
about inducing a dipole
moment of the virus with an
electrostatic
charged material for both on your
experience
what would be the proper option to
measure measure the interaction of the
fiber
virus to a surface fiber is there any
nano
particle last time i read about zn nano
particles
thank you very much for sharing your
knowledge
um i can i can comment on this and maybe
suzanne can
help as well um we have been testing
um some materials um just by
looking at uh what what is left after
incubating the virus with the materials
i think i'm not sure what the best
method is to really measure
um but it measure virus binding
the bioco instruments and other
analytical instruments that look at
biophysical principles of binding i
think would be the best option
uh of course you can't do sars live
stars with it but you could do
proteins with it suzanne do you have any
thoughts on it yeah thanks dr pereira
this is um slightly outside of my
expertise but i
one thing i would say is if you have
access to any kind of
imaging systems it's not just cells that
you can
image you can look at other
3d materials in there as well
and look at protein binding and things
like that using fluorescence
within those materials um so if you have
it doesn't have to be
a selego if you have some sort of
imaging platform
um in your laboratory and we can help
advise on on how you would image those
um those materials then with the virus
added
as well yeah i think
uh the salico actually would be perfect
because you could put the material down
on a plate and you could put the virus
on and then wash it several times
and uh probe the plate with the
antibodies against viral proteins
and image it using the seligo exactly
yeah i think that's definitely what we
could do with this illegal it would be
really interesting to see
as well yeah okay
uh next question is we don't see many 3d
models in virology research
does proper polarization of cells matter
for an in vitro models
so we do have 3d models of viruses
but i'm not sure if you're asking about
3d cell culture some viruses definitely
replicate better in polarized cells
i'm not sure if sars does or not
um but definitely three-dimensional
um cell culture models are
probably the way to go in the future
uh they are difficult to establish and
maintain
especially with consistency but i think
it's critical
that we look at cell cell interactions
and how they might impact virus
infection
and any therapeutic intervention
okay the next question is
um is there a downside to performing
micro neutralization assays in 384
well plates i i can i think i can answer
that
um i think as long as you have enough
material as long as you have a
significant amount of
cells and it's been tested and you have
replicas then there's no reason i don't
think
why you can't miniaturize your assays if
you do miniaturize from
let's say you go from a 96 to a 384 well
plate for those kind of assays
um you're going to get more replicas
some more data
um so i'd actually recommend doing
something at least testing it out to see
if you can get consistent results
in that miniature format
okay the next question is a kind of a
broad question
should we rely on a covid vaccine or
should we be thinking about combining
this with antiviral drugs too
so in traditionally antivirals have been
given
after you get sick and you go to the
hospital
so i think we need to focus to make sure
that
that has capacity so
a lot of the antivirus that are being
developed are to
treat after infection we do have the
option of
treating prior to infection and
certainly
that has to be investigated i think the
vaccine
vaccines have historically proven to be
incredibly effective at reducing
infection
so definitely a combination does help
but
um my i think my
uh confidence in vaccines is high
especially with the kind of technologies
and the effort scientists around the
world
are putting towards going vaccines
so yeah yeah i think just to add to that
there's um with this particular vaccine
that's just come out there's a um
it's really exciting um
but there's still a lot of data we need
to um
that needs to come out you know is it
working in those people that get the
severe
form of the disease we don't know yet is
there any after effects
um beyond um a couple of months we don't
know yet um
it does it affect does it um
does it stop people getting the virus
for longer than a couple of months
we don't know we don't know yet it
hasn't been tested
and also although it's super exciting i
still think we should be
not giving up on all the other research
that's going on
out there in terms of antivirals and
other vaccines as well because we just
don't know
um what the the end result for this one
is going to be
okay this person says thank you for your
this incredible presentation
as both presenters mention that with
technological
process progress the time and laboratory
processes are reduced i can't help but
wonder how the newer generations can
prepare for such an automated
environment
how can we gain more experience on such
automated processes
and this person is asking as a
biomedical sciences undergraduate
so i can take us attempt
answering it and then then you can help
i think i think there is a significant
amount of
human input that's required for
automated processes there's a lot of
decision making
in the up front of the experiment that
is important to be and to
be a good scientist to be able to design
the experiment well
uh the automated processes are basically
helping you to
speed up things that uh like readouts or
analysis or measurements uh what you get
at the end
are results which have to be critically
evaluated by scientists as well
undergraduates uh have to
really explore opportunities i have a
lot of undergraduates in my lab and they
have a phenomenal
experience because they get trained to
work in a bsl-2 lab
and if they're good and dedicated then
they get to work in a bsl3 lab
and so there's lots of opportunities for
undergraduates and they should all
try to join a research lab and get some
experience
yeah i don't have too much to add to
that i just absolutely
agree that the automated processes are
going to
help you get from a to b
but planning that process that also
needs to be i just think that's
exactly what i would say that it doesn't
um
it doesn't take away the um the science
and the thinking about why you're going
from a to b
you need to still do all of that work as
well
great advice um so the last question i
have
here is an interesting one uh what are
your thoughts on the mink variety of
covid found
in denmark should we be concerned
and do you think the current vaccine
approach uh
would work with that variation
oh i i'm not familiar with the
um variety of code found in denmark
does anyone else know yeah i ca i'm
familiar with it but
um i i don't think i can comment on what
on
species to species um
uh viability of the vaccine whether it
will work
i don't think unfortunately i don't
think um
the animal models of the virus are a
priority for the researchers at the
moment and i don't think mink is
something that they would have tested
anything in prior to it going into
humans either so
um i have no idea
maybe one i don't think that is going on
in
minks
i think people are i know my colleague
next door is going after
going to collect uh some of the viruses
in the minks
and um all the people studying animal
models are certainly going to test it
out
but what should be uh appreciated is
that there's always going to be a quasi
species so you're not getting one virus
particle
you're getting a family right and that
family has a relationship to each other
so
a lot of these vaccines and antivirals
will be effective against a quasi
species because that's what really even
in cell culture
you're not you don't have a single
species you do have a
collection of virus particles that are
slightly different to
each other so
the drugs and the vaccines are really
measuring that
but of course there will be larger
variations and that we have to address
that
i did have one more question come in um
they say great presentations
and are there any suggestions for how to
analyze
metabolites with cell-based assays or
traditionally mass spec
right so we uh we use um
mass pack uh which is the most powerful
way to analyze metabolites
but you can also analyze metabolites uh
using cell-based
assays for instance you know you have a
cholesterol test and you have a glucose
test
so there are lots of tests out there for
um different metabolites there are more
generic metabolites a lot of the
metabolizer we
study when we look at a whole human
or maybe serum saliva or urine of a
organism is a collection of metabolites
and
the way the the field is moving and the
way we are pushing the field
is to really identify groups of
metabolites
that identify a disease that are
biomarkers of a disease
so for instance if you want to know if a
patient who just got infected with sars
is going to have severe disease or maybe
mild disease
there might be a signature in the saliva
of
urine or the serum that might indicate
that
so it's not just one or two metabolites
but it's really a
group of metabolites
okay that concludes our questions that
we have for today
and um we appreciate you taking the time
to attend today's presentation
we ask that you complete a short survey
at the close of this webinar
your thoughts and comments would be
greatly appreciated
may you make sure you visit the poster
hall and the exhibit booths where you
can learn more about a variety of
exciting technologies
including some of the ones shared during
today's presentation
this webcast has been recorded and will
be available to view
on demand through july of 2021 everybody
have a really great day
thank you thank you